ναμεταγυρίσματα ερχόμο να πίσω κύπρο έλεγα τον φίλο μου της οικογένεας μετάτε να μας ζευτούμερα
δούμε το επισόδιο το πρώτο και δεν ήμονα πουθεν μετά συγδεοποίης ότι για να είσε
στο επισόδιο πρέπει όπυ υπάρχει κάμερα να συκησι εγώ που έβλεπα την κάμερα έτρεχα κάπου
αλλούπερίμενα ναμε δώ όμως και μετά με αυτό ήλθε συνεργασία με των ηλίαψυνάκι με να
ταξίδη κράτη σε αρκετά τι κράτας από αυτή η συνεργασία γιατί είναι ένας μήθος κακάταψηματα
είναι ο ηλαίας ψυνάκης εναι πντα ξε ο κόρυθές στον τομαα του με κλειστά τα
μάτια στην τότε η λικία μου δεκαοκτώ προςδεκανια χρονών μόλα αυτά που έβλεπα σα παιδί
από δώ απι κύπρο που βλέπαμε όλι τις συνεργασίες που έκανε των τρόπου που δούλευε
και ταλπα εγώ ημουναμαγεμένος απευθείας ισωσκεδιίό τρεις βδωμάδες πριν το κλήσιμο του παιχνιδιού μου έγινε
η πρόταση από τον ηία ψυνάκι δέκτικα εγώ περίμενα απλά να τελειώσει το σό για
να ξεκινήσει σηνεργασία πήρα πάρα πολλά μαθήματα από τον ηλία τον τρόπου που σκέπτεται στον
τρόπο που δουλεύει και τα λίπα πάνοντα θόριπως βεβαίως χωρίς λέξη άποψης στοτι θα κάνει
ο ηλίας εννοίτε αφέτηκα στα χέρια του υπάρχουν περιστατικά που θυμάς που ήταν ο τρόπος
που δούλευε ολίας ψυνάκης και θεσόκαρε σε σαγωνικά εντξιο έχω ότι τα πάντα από τον
ηλία καλύτερη του εμφάνηση την καλύτερηας το πούμε ρα παιδί μουο ηλεία θέπεζε με τα
μύτιατην αρα την αύρα την καλύτερη δηλαδή να έχουμε συνέντευξη καλή ώρο απως τώρα και
να νεγηλίας παραγγέλνι σεόλους τους δημοσιογράφους να φάνε να πιούνόλους αγκαγιά με αγάπη έχω δύο
όμως και ναείναι στα όρια αριξη πουνί δη διαδή το τι άκουσα γιατί επιθέσεις έχει
κάνει για το καλό της δουλιας το κεύ που έβλεπε ότι λοξο δρομούσε αυτό που
ήθελε έχω ότι τα πάντα από τον ηλία επαφέσ έχε τει μέχρη σημέρα